senator Elizabeth Warren boughs out of
another race to which she doesn't belong
Bernie Sanders desperately attacks Joe
Biden and president Trump goes on the
offensive I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressive VPN protect your
online privacy today and expressvpn
dot-com / Ben well I'm back I'm sorry I
missed the post Super Tuesday show we
were a little busy having a baby for
those who didn't know it was it was
pretty awesome let me just say dr.
Shapiro is an incredible badass I mean
she is just she was a warrior man I mean
she just battled through this thing it
was it was wild to watch it's pretty
incredible and this is the third time
I've watched her do it my wife is pretty
spectacular she has female super powers
I will get to that a little bit later on
in the show when we get to some things I
like and some things that I hate but I'm
excited to welcome into the world baby
Shapiro number three she is gorgeous
she's beautiful and her siblings just
love her it's it was I will say I was a
little worried that her siblings were
going to be upset because whenever you
had a new sibling to the family you have
to worry that the kids are gonna be like
well this up ends things but her older
sister is super into it her older
brother who's just a sweetie was is
really into it too just adorable
so really loving it and thanks for all
the notes I got a lot of notes from
people congratulating us we really
appreciate all of the all of the love
and support it's fantastic and and yes
I'm real happy about that also I never
got a chance to actually express my
feelings about the outcome of Super
Tuesday so I'm gonna spend a couple
minutes here expressing my feelings
about the outcome of Super Tuesday first
of all um who called it yep that's right
go back and listen to my show on Monday
right before Super Tuesday or my Super
Tuesday show right before the actual
election results came in and you will
hear me suggest that Joe Biden was gonna
win a majority of the delegates from
Super Tuesday and I will say some people
were calling it not that many but you
know when you're right you're right
no when you're wrong you're wrong I mean
I'm blowing as many as we gotten right
but at least when I'm right I get to Pat
myself on the back I'm actually growing
a third arm here to pat myself on the
back but that was really exciting the
new 538 primary forecast says that Joe
Biden is not only going to an a
plurality of the delegates there will be
no open convention Joe Biden is gonna
win a majority of the delegates now
according to 538 so Bernie Sanders is
absolutely toast this makes perfect
sense if you look at the polls in
it turns out you know it's a bad
strategy for winning primaries in
Florida coming out in favor of the
Castro regime and also saying that
Israel's a racist state you know a lot
of Democrats in Florida are Cuban and
Jewish that's a real bad strategy the
polls in Cuba actually look like polls
about Castro in Cuba I mean it's like
all for Joe Biden is like 65% Joe Biden
2% Bernie Sanders
nobody likes Bernie in Florida he's
gonna get whomped in Georgia there's a
good shot that he loses Michigan
so right now 538 suggests that Biden is
going to earn about 2300 delegates he
only needs nine in 1990 in order for him
to become the Democratic nominee
so Biden is right now the prohibitive
frontrunner and it is amazing how
quickly things shifted it was amazing
how quickly that anything like it in
politics it really was incredible I mean
in my entire lifetime of politics the
fast shift here was unbelievable why
because Joe Biden is a dead person right
all Joe Biden does go around and gaff he
just makes mistakes like even in the
middle of his of his big victory speech
on Super Tuesday he started speaking in
tongues he was misquoting poetry he
mixed up his wife and his sister which
immediately earned him at the
endorsement of Ilhan Omar it was really
weird right then the man's barely
sentient nothing changed about Joe Biden
only one thing happened here really only
one thing happened and that is that
Bernie Sanders looks much better as an
outsider than he does his an insider he
looks much better as the guy who is
outside sniping at the front-runner than
he does as the person who was the
front-runner because once all of the
focus turned on Bernie and he spent an
entire week defending the Castros
everybody's like oh that's a terrible
idea and everybody sort of went okay
well as if Biden wins South Carolina
we're all gonna resonate around by the
only question was whether it was gonna
be Biden or Bloomberg as the chief
opposition to Bernie Biden obviously is
much stronger than Bloomberg not only
because he has the history with Barack
Obama and more support in the black
community but also because Bloomberg
could perform horribly in the debates
and had no net level of national support
that was actually on the ground and
materialized so Biden ends up walking
away with this thing and as I say he is
now the prohibitive frontrunner now
that became even clearer when Elizabeth
Warren bowed out of the race we're gonna
get to that in just one second it is
delicious to watch all of these
candidates bow out of the race
Elizabeth Warren waited around for like
three days for no reason no
it just demonstrates she has no
political instincts at all Elizabeth
Warren I have I've rarely seen a
candidate blow a race the way Elizabeth
Warren blew this race I mean she blew
this race it is incredible get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about saving yourself time and saving
yourself money why would you slap a
bunch of packages over the post office
if you don't have to post office is
great but why would you like put
everything in the car bring it to the
post office maybe get a parking ticket
like it's it's a complete it's a
complete waste of time when you could do
all of this from home there's a reason I
personally like stamps calm and I
personally use stamps calm why waste
time and energy instead you can use the
interwebs and get everything done right
now stamps calm is completely online
plus you say five cents off every
first-class stamp in up to 40% off
shipping rates if there's a little bit
of agoraphobic thanks to coronavirus
this is perfect for you simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it once your mail is ready just hand it
to your mail carrier or you drop it in a
mailbox it is indeed that simple think
about how much time and money you could
have saved on letters and packages over
the years especially because stamps calm
gives you discounted postage rates you
can't even get at the post office
there's no equipment to lease no long
term commitments it is a no-brainer we
use it here at daily wire I use it
personally take advantage of things that
save you time and money if you run a
business particularly right now my
listeners get a special offer and
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage ands digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
calm enter code Shapiro stamps calm
enter code Shapiro okay so senator
Elizabeth Warren is out which is great
because she was awful just awful
off-putting annoying a congenital liar
just awful we actually have a clip of
her announcing because she's a Native
American right I mean that's what she
claimed for years we have a clip of her
announcing her her actual drop out it's
it's kind of sad it was it was a it was
a touching moment
terribly my Chiefs
I'm tired my heart is sick and sad
from where the Sun now stands I will
fight no more forever um guys that was
the wrong clip guys I mean yeah I by the
way okay no to media me making fun of
Elizabeth Warren for claiming she's
Native American is not me making fun of
Native Americans it's me making fun of a
horrible person who claims she was
Native American for years to gain
affirmative action benefits which is a
terrible thing to do okay so Elizabeth
Warren was awful in every everybody so
her actual concession speech her actual
I'm out of the race was basically I am
woman hear me roar like she actually
started singing Nancy Sinatra's these
boots are made for walking and walking
in what do you she's she's terrible okay
so so she did the whole I'm a woman I'm
a victim everyone's victimized okay let
me make something clear to Elizabeth
Warren if Elizabeth Warren were a man
should have performed like bado O'Rourke
except worse because beta was at least
from Texas Elizabeth Warren perform
horribly because she's a horrible
candidate she's a horrible candidate the
only reason that she was even at the top
of the race for one single solitary
moment is cuz she was woman the New York
Times endorsed her explicitly because
she was a woman the attention she got
was largely predicated on the supposed
connection she had with women by the way
she lost women in her home state of
Massachusetts to Joe Biden women voted
for Joe Biden over Elizabeth Warren so
what are all those women internalizing
the patriarchy or they find her just as
off-putting as the rest of sentient
human life does she's terrible
she's absolutely awful hey Elizabeth
Warren was going around doing the I was
victimized as a woman because when I was
pregnant I wasn't allowed to keep my job
which again there's no evidence to back
any of this she's she's done the whole I
experience sexism in the workplace
routine like really you're a victim
Elizabeth okay the reason that she lost
is because number one she's bad
candidate who does stupid things and
says stupid things and number two she
made a couple of basic strategic errors
strategic error number one early on in
the race Elizabeth Warren had a choice
you had to pick Elaine while she gonna
pick the left lane the Bernie Sanders
lane or was she gonna pick the moderate
Lane the Joe Biden lane she chose the
Bernie Sanders lane she figured that
Sanders the support would be easier to
steal than Joe Biden support and then
she could
over into the Biden Lane so she endorsed
medicare-for-all and that was the death
knell for her campaign because her
second move was to release a plan about
Medicare for all and as it turns out
Medicare for all is exorbitantly
expensive and you have to lie in order
to get to numbers that make sense and so
she lied to get to numbers that make
sense because she lies about everything
and people picked apart the lies and she
started to sink in the polls and so
elizabeth warren collapsed and so now
you're hearing from the media the same
sort of wailing you heard about Kamala
Harris Oh America's racist because they
didn't nominate Komal Harris No
Komal Harris isn't the nominee because
she was a garbage candidate Elizabeth
Warren is not the nominee she was a
garbage candidate but here's Elizabeth
Warren whining about there will never be
maybe there will never be a female
president now that my hopes have been
dashed okay first of all Elizabeth
Warren Hillary Clinton was the nominee
last time she won a majority of the
popular vote if she didn't been slightly
less lackluster she didn't have to be a
good candidate if she'd been slightly
less lackluster if she'd not collapsed
into a van in the last three weeks of
the campaign if she'd not had a story
breaking in The New York Times the
weekend before and they're reopening her
email investigation if she had not been
campaigning like a like a dunderhead
she's probably the president right now
Hillary Clinton
okay so spare me the America is sexist
it's the same it's amazing the left has
a premise the premise is that Americans
are awful and so every time Americans do
something that proves that they are not
awful even in the view of the left that
only lasts for the amount of time that
Americans are doing me not awful thing
then they go back to the default state
of being awful so when Barack Obama was
president Americans had proved for a
brief moment they were not racist
because we're the only westernized
country in human history that has
elected a person of a minority race to
the head of the country hey this has
never happened in Western Europe I'm not
aware of a single Western European
country that has ever elected somebody
of a racial minority to lead the country
the United States elected a member of a
racial minority black black Americans
represent not thirteen percent of the
population white Americans still
represent about 65 to 70 percent of the
population the they elected we the
American people I didn't vote for him
the American people an overwhelmingly
white country elected a black man to be
President of the United States and for
the moment the media was like oh maybe
Americans aren't so racist then Barack
Obama was no longer president and if you
didn't vote for Kamala Harris it was
because you were racist again okay well
last time around Democrats voted to
nominate Hillary Clinton and now
we got the entire laments that if if
Elizabeth Warren had been a man and she
would have been the nominee here if
Elizabeth Warren had been a man she
wouldn't have been she'd have been one
of the first candidates out if she'd
been a man I mean just a fact but here
she was whining about there being no
female president the women and girls who
feel like we're electric two white men
to decide between I know one of the
hardest parts of this is all those
parents and all those little girls who
thinks that little girls are sitting
around well I have a six-year-old girl
you think she's sitting around going I
can't believe Elizabeth Lawrence out
because about there's not a female
president you know my daughter doesn't
give two craps about this you know why
cuz nobody does because if you're a
little girl in the United States you are
living the best life that any little
girl has ever lived okay girls in the
United States have wonderful incredible
lives on average the the idea that you
had to make a woman president elizabeth
warren brett by the way they're not
gonna have any of these nice where it's
nikki Haley when she's running in 2024
are they when you have a Republican
woman running remember how they treated
Sarah Palin you remember all the female
solidarity around Sarah Palin as the VP
candidate remember how all the women
came out of the woodwork and talked
about how wonderful it was that there
was a female VP candidate yeah I don't
remember that either cuz it never
happened instead of what she's not a
real woman that was the that was the rep
she wasn't a real woman also just quick
note I'm always amused by Democrats like
Elizabeth Warren who suggest it is
imperative we must have a female
president deeply deeply necessary to
have a female president also a man can
be a woman okay we're gonna have to pick
either gender is a social construct and
therefore does not matter Ann is
completely malleable or female this
matters and you need a female president
you can't huh you cannot have it both
ways
this is the same woman who suggested
that she was going to have her tits
education secretary appointed by a
nine-year-old transgender child so
you're gonna need to explain to me like
if Donald Trump declared himself a woman
tomorrow could Elizabeth Warren complain
about it if Donald Trump came out and
was like guess what guys boom I'm the
first female president didn't see that
one coming did you hahahahaha good
what would Elizabeth Warren have to say
about that he should do it just it just
to get her goat it would be hysterically
funny hey Elizabeth morning just proving
how terrible she is she also said she
would issue no endorsements Bernie
Sanders hardest hit so Bernie but she's
taken about ten percent of the vote from
Bernie probably eight to ten percent of
the vote and unlike Klobuchar or Buddha
jej who immediately went in rallied for
Joe Biden Warren will not endorse
Sanders now the reason she won't endorse
Sanders is because she hopes that Joe
Biden will give her some sort of
administration slot and she's still
lobbying for some sort of upward
trajectory Sanders is basically begging
her right Sanders says wife course I'd
put a little in my administration
sure she called me a liar and I called
her a liar and we both hated each other
but I mean if it means that she'll throw
her minimum support to me then I will do
it I suppose then I guess I will do it
here's Bernie saying that he would give
Warren a slot in his administration
which again is about as much of a
fantasy as his communist utopia which
will not materialize in the United
States they're asking someone are
wanting to be a running mate it's too
early to talk about that but certainly I
have a lot of respect for Senator Warren
and would love to sit down with talk to
her about what kind of role she can play
in our administration by the way if he
does that his first word should be
remember that time I told you that if
you ran you would fail ha ha remember
that time I told you remember you said
on the national debate stage that I told
you that a woman could not win the
nomination well you could pay up at this
check-in counter right here right now
Elizabeth Warren Warren by the way says
no no no I'm not gonna endorse anybody
I'm too busy
sound of systole navel-gazing here she
is
will you be making an endorsement today
we know that you spoke with both Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders yesterday not
today not now today I need space around
this and want to take a little time to
think a little more I've been I've been
spending a lot of time right now on the
question of suspending and also making
sure that this works as best we can for
our staff or team for our volunteers it
could be coming but just not right now
thank you okay she's so awful right
because right now if she endorsed
Sanders it actually would actually give
him above but she's not gonna do it
so she's so selfish and terrible that
she supposedly is from medicare-for-all
and all the Bernese radical plans and
the problem is that Bernie just can't
materialize them except she's a garbage
person so she won't even endorse him so
really solid stuff she gets exactly what
she deserves but in a second we're gonna
get to the widespread morning for a
candidacy that was an epic failure epic
failure remember back in October she was
the presumptive nominee back in October
she was leading the National polling she
was leading a lot of the state polling
she had an organization a ground game in
Iowa New Hampshire
wow what a collapse by Elizabeth Warren
we'll get to the media just we Big O
over Elizabeth Warren in just one second
first let us talk about a simple fact
there's a lot of crime going on in your
area but in your neighborhood I didn't
even know how much crime was going like
I knew there was crime in my
neighborhood I've seen crimes being
committed in my neighborhood but until
you actually use rings neighborhood app
you don't know what kind of crimes are
being committed your neighbor who had
some breaking and entering okay this is
one of the reasons it's good because I
can actually see what's happening and
where these crimes are happening but one
of the reasons why I should have ring
and you should have ring devices on your
home so you know what's going on on your
property at all times ring gives you
protection at every corner helps you
create custom affordable security for
your home rings video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime from anyone which makes me
feel a lot of comfort I got small kids
at home I want to make sure my property
is safe at all times and again a lot of
street crime in the area that I live
it's been going up because of the
garbage government of Los Angeles well I
wanna make sure that my home is
protected so that I can even call the
police
remotely even if I'm not at home and I
can see something's going on in my
property ring does all of this stuff
ring detects motion when people come
onto your property and you immediately
receive notifications on your phone
tablet or PC and then you can see here
and speak to these visitors in real time
from anywhere get a special offer on
your ring welcome kit when you go to
ring comm / Ben that includes the ring
video doorbell - and chime pro it's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring.com / Ben again ring.com / Ben go
check them out right now ring calm /
been and get a special offer on that
ring welcome kit includes the video
doorbell and the D chime Pro check them
out bring calm / Ben okay so the media
continue to maintain that this is all
about Elizabeth Warren being a girl and
not about Elizabeth Warren being a
terrible candidate so this was the the
constant statement Kamala Harris another
failed candidate she says well I have
legitimate questions about whether it's
hard to be a woman your
question should be why you with every
intersectional advantage one of the
first candidates to drop out maybe
you're just bad at your job maybe it's
that again
the New York Times only endorsed
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar
because they're both women that is the
only reason because Warren and Klobuchar
disagree on a lot of things they
endorsed both because they were women
stop telling me that being a woman in
American politics is this grave
disadvantage when Democrats nominated
the popular vote winner a woman last
time and when all of the immediate
conventional wisdom frontrunners in the
Democratic primaries were women like
Kamala Harris and Elizabeth Warren and
just flamed out cuz they're bad here's
Kamala Harris whining I think that we
all know and this election cycle in
particular has also presented very
legitimate questions about the
challenges of women running for
president of the United States what do
you say that just look at what's
happened look at what's out there
there are no women currently in this
race and I you know we can have a longer
discussion about it but the reality is
that there's still a lot of work to be
done to make it very clear that women
are exceptionally qualified incapable of
being the commander-in-chief of the
United States of America okay
tulsi gabbard standing over Lee hey I've
got all the genetics I'm over here big
Tulsi gabbard's sold the race by the way
all these others are not Elysee just
laughing at them okay but but Kamala
Harris saying that there are so many
questions to be answered okay again
maybe the question that needs to be
answered is why you're terrible at your
job
maybe that's the question we should
start asking it's it's so it's it's
incessantly ridiculous truly these are
all Democratic voters by the way so
they're ripping on their own Democratic
base they're saying that Democratic
voters are a bunch of sexist
so enjoy they've already called their
own voting base sexist and racist I hope
they continue to do this Rachel Maddow
complain about the solution this is a
death nail a death nail for women for
president
sure it is sure does what's going on is
that women around the country are like
okay honestly you know if it's not it's
not going to be any of them let's get
real is it just is it just that it can't
be any woman ever are we just going to
run you know white men in there
870's against each other both parties
and that's all we can agree to do I
think there's a there's a feeling that
your campaign ending is is very specific
to you and it also feels a little bit
like a death knell in terms of the
prospects of having a woman for
president in our lifetime I'm sorry this
just this is tiresome garbage cuz Nikki
Haley's gonna run in 2024 and you know
it's gonna happen all these same people
are gonna viciously attack her and say
that she's not a real woman that's
what's gonna happen
it's had they viciously attack Ivanka
Trump there's not a they viciously
attack Megan McCain is not a real woman
I cannot think of a conservative woman
they will not viciously attack is not a
real woman so spare me the gender
solidarity bullcrap also spare me this
nonsense because women in Massachusetts
her home state voted for Joe Biden did
they all internalize the patriarchy are
all of them people who hate women like
you're gonna have to explain this it's
just it's so self-serving and ridiculous
of all the self-serving nonsense this
probably was my favorite annex Hillary
aide came out of national television and
said well you know what what we really
need what we user Lena Maxwell she
worked as director of progressive media
for Hillary Clinton she said that that
Elizabeth Warren was done better if she
were a man false fat check false also
she suggested that you know we need men
to push for women to lead not just to
wait till they of wives and daughters to
realize that women are people too how
about women realize that women are
people too and some women are better
than others at particular things how
about that but no apparently all women
women so do things I've learned from the
media in the last few years
believe all women women never lie and
every woman who runs for president
should win alternatively that's a bunch
of crap and some women are great at
politics in some women suck at politics
and some women lie and some women tell
the truth just like all other human
beings
here's ralina Maxwell being a dolt I
find it interesting
mostly men say this and this is not
students because I'm on set with two men
I'd say it's not you guys but we have
never had a woman president and for some
reason only it seems like only women are
concerned about this fact and I would
like more wet more men to be vocal about
the fact that they want to see women in
positions of leadership don't say oh
well we can just pick Carla as the vice
president why does a woman have
settle for the number two job 20 hold on
she's not settling for anything she
didn't earn the votes you don't get to
choose which position you hold okay you
know many Americans would like to be
President a lot you don't get to choose
why does she have to settle she has to
settle because she failed because she
flamed up she was a crap candidate this
is such a dog again goes to this basic
narrative this basic left-wing narrative
which is that equality of outcome is the
only proof that equality of opportunity
was provided that only if an equal
number of women and men end up as
president did women have the opportunity
to run for president and that's just not
true
it's not true maybe some of these
candidates were bad maybe Joe Biden had
an inherent advantage because he was
vice president maybe Bernie Sanders had
an inherent advantage because he's been
running for president for the west's the
last four years non-stop and had a
built-in base it turns out that the two
most viable candidates from the
beginning with the largest bases were
also the candidates who are there at the
end is that any grave shock not really I
mean I sort of analyzed it that way when
when Biden and Bernie first jumped in I
said was gonna be a two-person race so
it's so again the whole thing is very
very similar okay the second we got to
Bernie versus Joe Bernie on his last
legs here which is just delicious in the
New York Times coming in from the ropes
and just crushing Bernie no they're
there they're all in providing at this
point we'll explain in just one second
first let's talk about those days
remember those days where you would get
the newspaper and actually have to cut
out coupons or you'd look in the mail
and oh a Bed Bath and Beyond coupons
yeah well that was really irritate I
read my mind had an entire drawer filled
with coupons and what I didn't have to
do any of that stuff and what if you
even have to go online and look for
promo codes what if there was an app
that did it all for you and just gave
you the automatic discounts well lucky
for you there is it's honey know that
honey is the free online shopping tool
that automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your card you
know how great it feels to save but how
does it feel the same with honey it
feels amazing because again it just runs
in the background of your computer every
single time I check out after I buy
something honey tries to apply promo
codes I have saved probably thousands of
dollars at this point using honey it
works on all the major websites ranging
from amazon to ebay like honey is
constantly looking for deals for you did
you know that honey supports over 30,000
stores online that includes directly
stores like Macy's targets and for a
Best Buy and more they're adding more
every single day honey has found it's
over 18 million members over two billion
dollars in savings as I say it saved my
fam
thousands of dollars using honey feels
amazing think of it as a little daily
victory over the marketplace plus it is
free to use and installs in just a few
seconds get honey for free at join honey
calm slash Ben again that's join honey
calm slash Ben join honey calm slash man
go check them out right now okay so mean
well as I say Bernie Sanders is on his
last legs of this campaign
5:38 suggests that bernie is about to
collapse they are now giving joe biden
an 88% shot at winning a majority of the
delegates and so bernie is running out
this slog his supporters are deeply
unhappy they are claiming of course that
he's getting jobs in all of this and
they're getting increasingly vicious and
nasty so it's fun to watch Bernie and
Biden go at each other so Bernie and
Biden we now have Statler and Hofstadter
from the from the Muppet Show oh yeah
Bernie what do you think about this show
this show is terrible ah it's a Bernie
and Joe Biden going at each other so
Biden texts it out
here's the deal folks Social Security is
on the ballot this year and the choice
couldn't be clearer I'll protect and
expand it Donald Trump will cut it and
take it away
and Bernie tweeted back at him here's
the deal Joe Biden has repeatedly I
think if the cuts total currently I
my whole career to protect and
expand it and Joe Biden in response
Kerry or Gary Oh Bernie
the only person is going to cut Social
Security if he's really elected it's
Donald Trump maybe you should spend your
time attacking him is in ring and then
Bernie responds good we'll talk one of
us has a history of not only fighting
cuts to Social Security but working to
expand benefits and that's why we are
the campaign best positioned to defeat
Donald Trump
so all been shouting at each other so if
you like if you like the sort of thing
let me recommend a movie grumpy old men
Walter Matthau Jack Lemmon in a
late-stage and Margaret fairly solid
movie and what more entertaining than
this watching old people shouted each
other the old age hum it's really really
entertaining Sanders is opening up his
guns he's saying Joe is getting Wall
Street money now the fact is that it's
amazing like the most telling attacks on
each other the Democrats just will not
use like why has Sanders not attacked
hunter Biden yet why how is that a
possibility
why is Sanders
attack the facts that Joe Biden is not a
sentient human there okay it is not
wrong to be seriously concerned about
Joe Biden's age and decrepitude it is
not the man is blundering every which
way every which way and the media you
know Twitter just established a rule
today this is hilarious Twitter just
established a rule that you are not
allowed to make jokes that they expanded
their hateful conduct rules to include
language that G humanizes on the basis
of age disability or disease just in
time for Joe Biden to win the nomination
so there go okay boomer there go all of
my jokes about Joe Biden I guess we
can't make fun of the fact that Joe
Biden has the same mental functioning
capacity as one of the plants in the
background of the show at this point I'm
not saying he's a vegetable he's not a
vegetable I'm saying that he is a form
of plant life that may or may not be a
vegetable he's a lot of cellulose is all
I'm saying I mean Joe Biden just
yesterday seemingly forgets Barack
Obama's name the man who worked for like
again you got to feel a little I'd feel
bad for him if she's gonna get the
nomination Joe Biden is not all there
okay I have both my grandmother's are
still alive okay one is 95 and one is 90
if they are both in better mental
functioning health and Joe Biden is at
this point here here is here is Joe
Biden forgetting the president he worked
for while declaring that he runs for his
hunt like how is Sanders not going after
this it's amazing
my boss is his fault it was President my
boss
you mean President Obama the man you
worked for the only reason that you're a
front-runner right now how Sanders not
going after that instead standards is
just gonna keep doubling down on the
communism he says Joe's gonna be well
sweeper bubbling it's all about the
water you know what attack doesn't work
this one you tried it on Peabody judge
it didn't really do much damage you've
tried on pretty much everybody Bernie
and it ain't going anywhere
what you're saying is Wall Street
opening up its checkbook to Jabba you're
saying Mike Bloomberg worth some sixty
billion dollars prepared to support yeah
he's he's toast he's toast and not only
is he toast the reason he's toast is
because he's burning now here's the bad
news is that in the future the
Socialists could run a non geriatric
uncharred Grampa who shouts at the moon
and they could run somebody who's
actually better at this than Bernie
Sanders that's what I'm afraid of in the
future for the Democratic Party but
Bernie is an old commie talk about a
story by the way that should have been
run in 2016 the New York Times has a
story today titled as Bernie Sanders
pushed for closer ties soviet union
spotted opportunity previously unseen
documents from a soviet archive show how
hard mr. sanders worked to find a sister
city in russia when he was mayor in the
1980s Moscow saw a chance for propaganda
no bleep has been taped of Bernie
floating around for years shirtless in
the Soviet Union only now does the New
York Times he fit to point out the fact
that the Soviet Union was using the man
as a fellow traveler of course they were
that's what the Soviets did but we're
supposed to believe that Bernie was some
sort of good-hearted non commie
according to the New York Times the
mayor of Burlington Vermont wrote to his
Soviet counterpart in a provincial City
he wanted the US and the Soviet Union's
who quote lived together ends unbeknown
to him his desire for friendship meshed
with the efforts of Soviet officials in
Moscow to quote reveal American
imperialism as the main source of the
danger of war so in other words they saw
him as a useful idiot and they used him
as a useful idiot
the New York Times examined 89 pages of
letters telegrams and internal Soviet
documents revealing in far greater
detail the extent of Sanders his
personal effort to establish ties
between his city and a country many
Americans
still considered an enemy they also show
how the Kremlin viewed these sister city
relationships as vehicles to sway
American public opinion about the Soviet
Union collusion corruption collusion
except real a Soviet Foreign Ministry
document said one of the most useful
channels in practice for actively
carrying out information propaganda
efforts has proved to be sister city
contact the documents are part of a
government archive in Russia which
became the sister city of Burlington in
Yaroslavl the files are open to the
public but here's the key until now no
one had asked to see them until now he's
been running for president since 2016
only now only now the Sanders campaign
does not dispute the documents
authenticity the documents are included
in a file titled documents about the
developments of friendly relations of
the city of Yaroslavl with the City of
Burlington in 1988 in a statement the
Sanders campaign said the candidate was
proud of his grassroots diplomatic
efforts he just doubles down on the
communism and that's why bernie is
basically toast instead so Sanders
reached out to the Soviet Union he
basically did prep for them he did
propaganda work for them claiming that
the US was responsible for the Cold War
and all of the rest amazing that it took
the media this long to figure it out
okay so in a second we're gonna get to
Donald Trump and how he has been
responding to all of this but first let
us talk about how you can protect your
online activity even if I were not a
public figure I would be deeply
concerned about people stealing my data
I mean I've had my credit card stolen
online before it is no fun but as a
public figure I'm super concerned and
that's why I use the VPN I've been using
a VPN for years you should use a VPN -
there's just too many people out there
who want your data go check out right
now expressvpn expressvpn encrypts 100%
of your data with the best-in-class
encryption so your information is always
protected even when you're using public
Wi-Fi like at a cafe or in a hotel even
if you're using incognito mode by the
way it is not enough your online
activity can still be traced even if you
clear your browsing history your
internet service provider can see every
single website you've ever visited so
you thought that you were free and clear
you are not my friend incognito didn't
do the trick
you need a VPN expressvpn works on
everything phones laptops routers
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can still
be protected even if they don't have
express VPN and listen it's very easy to
get a VPN so if you don't protect
yourself that
is sort of on you protect your online
activity today with the VPN I trust to
secure my privacy visit my special link
at expressvpn comm slash Ben and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
Ben expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn
more go check them out right now okay
before we go any further it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily water subscriber
today it's carly flanders on twitter
who's doing parenting 100% correctly in
this picture Carly is sitting next to
her husband who was wearing a fantastic
fax don't care shirt and holding up his
elite beverage vessel Carly is holding
up their very show very adorable baby
it's a cute baby who's wearing a fax
don't care about your feelings onesie
yes the caption reads Ben Shapiro real
daily we're teaching her young hashtag
leftist ears tumblr hashtag fax don't
care about your feelings
it's true that isn't that is nailing the
parenting game right there
thanks for the pick Carly Congrats to
you both on the growing family also
Super Tuesday is finally over the super
savings remain so we're continuing to
give you 25% off all daily wire
memberships with coupon code and never
socialist grab this deal while it lasts
it won't be around much longer much like
Bernie Sanders candidacy daily where
members get an ad-free website they get
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show access to the mailbag
and now exclusive election insight
op-eds from me yes indeed daily wire
members also get to ask us questions
live like many of you saw on our super
tuesday coverage on backstage which was
interminable and endless and also wildly
entertaining along with all of this of
course to get the magnificent the
irreplaceable these singular the
incomparable left us to tears tumblr if
you haven't already download the daily
water app so you can get all of our
great content on the go again 25% off
daily wire memberships right now for all
plans just use coupon code never
socialists head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe act now before
it is indeed too late that is daily wire
calm slash
subscribe you to listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so Joe Biden who is now
sailing to the nomination he is claiming
that he is going to beat President Trump
of course he says that he is the person
best positioned to be President Trump
now to analyze that claim first of all
here is Joe Biden the the greatest
obstacle to Joe Biden being president is
the fact that the man is no longer fully
functional and that that is in fact the
greatest obstacle and as we'll see
Donald Trump is still a very lively
human being he's very funny he's very
lively he's excellent on the stump it's
hard to get enthusiastic about Biden
that also means it's hard to get
enthusiastic about getting out to stop
Joe Biden but Trump John's drive up the
enthusiasm of his base really high there
there are a couple of specific areas
look Trump knees trying to discipline
campaign if he wants to win he needs to
run the discipline campaign I think
there are a lot of Republicans right now
are whistling past the graveyard a
little bit I think there are a lot of
Republicans right now for a little bit
too sanguine
about Trump's chances against Joe Biden
they're looking at the polling they're
saying well the polling is is early
that's true it is early it is also true
that early polling has generally been
kind of close to what final presidential
polling looks like for example back in
2012 Barack Obama had a fairly low
approval rating at this same time Barack
Obama running against Mitt Romney Romney
was just wrapping up the nomination in
2012 Barack Obama was skulking him by
somewhere between 7 and 10 points and
all the polls he ends up winning by like
five points yeah Joe Biden right now in
all the polls all the national polls is
leading Donald Trump pretty
significantly and that means that Trump
has some ground to make up it also means
that Trump is gonna have to run a
disciplined campaign where he doesn't
get in his own way that said Trump does
have a couple of pretty rich lines of
attack on Biden one of course is hunter
Biden which we'll get to in a second the
other is that Joe Biden is not with us
here is here is Joe Biden who has
checked out not all of the bats are in
the belfry not all of the lights are on
in the attic not all of the cookies are
in the cookie jar here here is Joe Biden
one thing the president does want to do
from the very beginning is face me
because I will beat him period period he
has done everything in his power
he's even risk his presidency because he
doesn't want to face me a rhetorical
question have you ever ever seen a city
president gets so involved in a
Democratic primary
and focus so much attention on not
wanting a single person me to become the
nominee the President does not want me
to be the nominee okay so this is Joe
Biden's claim here as president Trump's
response to all that he says yeah I was
said for Bernie but now you know I guess
I'll go after you if I have to here's
the thing that Trump dude has no limits
he is a WWE wrestler he will pick up a
folding chair he will hit Joe Biden
physically with the folding chair the
man will jump from the top rope giant
orange wrestler coming at you here is
he's the man said he's hysterically
funny okay put up put everything else
aside Donald Trump is he very funny
human being here is Donald from going
after both Bernie Sanders and then just
sideswiping Joe Biden so you want to
face Joe Biden or Bernie Sanders that's
my question okay I was all set for
Bernie because I thought it was gonna
happen you know we get ready for things
right so mentally I'm all set for Bernie
communist I had everything down he's a
[Applause]
crazy thing that happened right on
Tuesday which he thought was Thursday
but he also said a hundred and fifty
million people were killed with guns and
he was running for the United States
Senate support me I'm running for the
United says there's something going on
there he's a comedian I mean he is a
stand-up and he has the timing of a
stand-up like he waits for the laughter
to roll and then he goes he's very funny
I mean this is what people love about
Trump and again in a debate he could
really show up Joe Biden cuz Joe Biden
all he has to do is really pull the
chris Christie all yes to say is Joe you
can't get through a sentence here and
then you might be like well I was in
Genova Xenu a Big Joe just spit it out
and she'll be like I can't believe
you're saying this about Chavez did you
people go Mac Shambu I mean it's it's
gonna get ugly it's gonna get ugly
really really quickly
now listen Trump isn't isn't fully in
command of the English language either
I've suggested that a Trump Biden debate
is gonna be the Swedish Chef versus
Chewbacca but with that said Trump is at
least awake I mean Joe Biden has been
unconscious for the past several years
he's a president Trump also says listen
I'm not gonna sit
okay this is not gonna be me running a
non-aggressive race he was asked about
you know are you off putting two people
in the middle of the countries listen
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna not hit back
if I get hit which is one of the things
his supporters absolutely love there's a
Gallup poll out today so I'm Republican
enthusiasm to vote is that an all-time
high that makes perfect sense here is
here's Trump I think the way we united
is really through a success but when
they hit us we have to hit back I feel
that I mean there's two ways of doing it
turning your cheek but I wouldn't be
sitting up here if I turned my cheek if
I said okay let them just keep hitting
at me and I won't do it they're not
interviewing me right now they're
interviewing somebody else maybe they
won't even be doing that because if they
don't get ratings they don't interview
anybody you know what you can't turn
your teeth okay so he's gonna be like
this all the way through right here the
president Trump is never gonna back away
from the aggressiveness and that has its
downsides which is that he says things
that are wild and and a lot of people
find off-putting and it has his upside
which is that he is a weapon against
Biden so the real question in this
election is going to be whether Trump
can again make it a referendum on his
opposition that's much harder with Joe
Biden than it would be on Bernie right
with Bernie it's very obvious how you go
after Bernie Bernie's a threat to the
country like a real actual threat to the
country the fact that Bernie lost and is
falling apart is excellent it's good
news for the country it means that maybe
we still have something in common
namely that we don't think the communism
would be better for the society than
capitalism namely that we don't think
that America is an inherently evil place
rooted in her horrifying principles okay
but as a candidate Biden is harder to
attack why won't one he's been around
longer - he's a shapeshifter
right that's where Trump's really gonna
hit him is that he's taken every
position on every possible issue and and
three Biden is not uncommon right I
don't like Joe Biden I don't find him
all that all that effective or charming
but he's not like Hillary one of the
questions that Trump has to be asking
about Biden is who is Biden going to
lose that Hillary won if you want Biden
win fewer votes than Hillary who is
Biden going to lose that Hillary won
it's hard to come up with that answer
which means that Trump needs to win some
additional votes it means that Trump
needs to win some additional votes but
all of that is predicated on the idea
that everything is baked into the cake
with Biden I'm not sure that is the case
because again the media have sort of
been shielding us all from the downsides
of Joe Biden like all the attacks from
Biden have been from the
but he's not been hit from the right on
anything yet
Joe Biden and there are some pretty rich
areas where he could hit Joe Biden from
the right namely that Joe Biden presided
over a pretty bad administration the
Obama administration was not bad his
record in the Obama administration was
not good Obamacare has been a pretty
large scale failure Joe Biden has been
in Congress forever and it's gotten
really not a lot done and the stuff that
he has gotten done he's apologized for
like the crime bill and most of all Joe
is real vulnerable on the hunter stuff I
know that people in the media are trying
to downplay the hunter stuff in the same
way they downplayed Hillary's emails in
Benghazi and all the rest of it that's
not going to work there are serious
questions to be asked about why every
member of the Biden family has got rich
off the Biden name now you're gonna see
the Democrats try the same thing with
Trump they're gonna suggest the Jared
and Ivanka are getting rich off of Trump
they're gonna suggest that everybody in
Trump's family is working under the
Trump rubric yeah the difference is that
Trump is a mud monster as I've said
before Trump is not vulnerable to
character attacks because people don't
think he has tons of character Joe Biden
is fairly well thought of right people
have good opinions about Joe Biden as a
person that means he also has further to
fall that's a problem for him so here is
Donald Trump saying listen Biden is
damaged right Biden is a damaged Kendon
he's gonna be further damaged by the
time is silver I think Biden has been
damaged yeah a lot of people I took a
couple of statements very strong
statements by very respected people in
your world saying they aimed at Trump
that they took Biden down and really
that's what happened when you think
because you look at the son okay he is
he is not going to hold back here Trump
was on Sean Hannity show he said the
same thing he said it's crazy the
Democrats did not hit hunter Biden it's
not a campaign issue for the Democrats
they don't want to bring it up they were
obviously told you can't bring that up
so even people that are against if you
look at Joe they're against Joe they
don't want to bring that up that was off
bounds I watched certain reporters say
that this is totally unsubstantiated and
we're starting to even ask you a
question
Anderson Cooper said he asks the
question at what are the debates that it
was so mild and a ridiculous answer is
given because there is no answer to it
of course it's corrupt Tom's a bulldog
and he and that's the problem for that
is the B's problem for Biden
one his incipient senility
and to the fact that Joe Biden actually
is well thought of and from his
specialty is dragging people through the
mud okay there's one other asset okay
there's one other asset that that that
Trump has here and that is people tend
to think that Trump is you know this
out-of-the-box guy I've said it before
people tend to think that Trump is the
guy who ruined American politics he's so
terrible he's so awful at every way just
awful just terrible okay there's only
one problem with that Donald Trump did
not kill American politics he is not the
murderer he is the coroner so for all of
the off-putting things that Trump says
all the terrible things that Trump says
and he says off-putting terrible things
sometimes we've been here for quite a
while for like a long time and Chuck
Schumer proved it over the last 48 hours
so Chuck Schumer spoke on Wednesday at
this event outside the Supreme Court
we'll talk a little bit later on in the
show about that events outside the
Supreme Court it was wild but Chuck
Schumer the Senate Minority Leader spoke
at this event outside the Supreme Court
protesting because inside the Supreme
Court they're deciding on whether a
Louisiana law that restricts abortion
clinics to having to have inpatient
privileges whether whether that law is
legal so Chuck Schumer is speaking about
abortion and he openly threatens two
Supreme Court justices like just
actively threatens them so here is Chuck
Schumer doing this again bad politics
vile politics saying horrible things
threats brutality in rhetoric and
politics did not start with Donald Trump
and anyone who says that they that it
did is lying to you openly here is Chuck
Schumer who's been on Capitol Hill since
before I was a child it's saying exactly
the sort of thing that you would expect
to hear from Trump it was amazing the
way the media covered this by the way
was unbelievable the media will here at
Schumer said the media covered this as
Republicans pounced and also Trump does
the same thing so why is it a big deal
Schumer does it now you're getting it
wrong guys if Trump is the outlier you
can't then claim that Schumer is just
doing what Trump does that doesn't make
Trump an outlier anymore here's the fact
Trump was never as much of an outlier as
people wish that he had been here's
here's Chuck Schumer I want to tell you
Gorsuch I want to tell you Kavanagh you
have released the whirlwind and you will
pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions okay
so they're sitting justices Supreme
Court justices sitting for a lifetime
that means that what will face them
exactly the only consequences that can
face them are presumably impeachment or
death right I mean that would be it
those are the only consequences that are
possible so what the hell does that mean
it's a vile thing to say John Roberts
who usually is pretty quiet about this
stuff he then tried 'add Schumer he
suggested it was irresponsible and
dangerous he said this morning Senator
Schumer spoke at a rally in front of the
Supreme Court while a case was being
argued inside
Senator Schumer referred to two members
of the court by name and said he wanted
to tell them that you have released the
world booing and you will pay the price
you will not know what hit you Robert
said justices know the criticism comes
with the territory but threatening
statements of this sort from the highest
levels of government are not only
inappropriate they're dangerous all
members of the court will continue to do
their job without fear or favor from
whatever quarter Schumer spokesperson
then suggested that Schumer was
addressing Republican lawmakers when he
said a price would be paid okay we just
played the clip obviously he's not
talking about Senate lawmakers he's
specifically talking about Supreme Court
justices okay so Schumer then gets
attacked by Mitch McConnell so Mitch
McConnell ripped on Schumer correctly
from the floor of the Senate here Senate
Majority Leader there is nothing to call
this except a threat and there's
absolutely no question to whom to whom
it was directed the ménard leader of the
United States Senate threatened to
associate justices of the US Supreme
Court period there's no other way to
interpret that that obviously is true
Schumer then denied threatening the
justices but admits you shouldn't have
used the words that he did and so the
the purpose of all of this is to point
out one quick thing if Democrats are
going to claim that Donald Trump is a
political outlier that Donald Trump is
vile and terrible in heretofore
unprecedented ways you can't act like
this but they are acting like this and
guess what
I been acting like this for quite a
while in over the last 48 hours Bill
Clinton came out and said that he was
nailing Monica Lewinsky cuz he was
stressed about his job you guys have
been here for a while Donald Trump was
not the murderer he is the coroner I
think most Americans understand that
okay
time for a couple of things that I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like
one as I mentioned new baby that is
anything I love that is awesome so
babies are fantastic also it's a
superpower it is a superpower like what
women do is unbelievable
when women say they're strong and
they're like yeah we can throw baseballs
fast man it's like no you can't and they
say well we're strong we can we can pick
up heavy objects no that's not what
makes you a strong woman you know what
makes you a strong woman taking a human
being and growing a human being in your
body and then pushing a human being out
of your body and then being able to feed
the human being with your like that's a
superpower man that is unbelievable it's
so I mean I've been privileged to watch
it three times with my wife it's
incredible on every level level my wife
is a tough cookie she is a tough cookie
she is just she's awesome
all praise - my wife is people always
say coming up and saying your muscles
huffing congratulations and how are you
doing like I'm fine I knew anything I
got all the good parts right I got the
beginning and I got the end that's
pretty much it right I got the I got the
production process and then I got the
receipt fantastic my wife had to do all
of the all of the hard lifting here and
good for her I mean it's it's an amazing
thing thank God everybody's doing well
my wife is doing fine she's perfectly
healthy the baby is perfectly healthy
her siblings are loving her which is
just as a parent I can tell you the
amount of nachus right which is sort of
the pride that you get from your
children treating each other well is
unending and my daughter is wonderful
with her sister my son is wonderful with
his sister it's a blast we're really
enjoying it yeah we're short on the
sleep but it's the best thing in the
world so that is definitely it's not
just a thing I like that is a thing that
I love and thank you all who tweeted to
me and and sent me emails it really is
appreciated my wife appreciates it Stu
appreciates it too it's awesome okay
other things that I like so my wife and
I in the in the lead-up to the birth
because we thought this baby was coming
like three weeks ago
I'm moving on red alert for three weeks
we we spent the last week or so doing a
Christopher Nolan marathon which is it
is the best way to welcome a baby into
the world in fact it's very funny last
pregnancy my wife was she was in labor
and I happen to be wearing a Batman
shirt and it was a picture of Batman
it's like from one of the comic books
maybe was Arkham Asylum it was a picture
of Batman like growling like giving the
you know and in my wife found it very
inspiring during labor and so actually
brought it with us to the hospital
I mean for the pushing the baby came so
fast you'd enough to use it but we were
doing our Christopher Nolan marathon we
are in the middle of almost finished
with the Dark Knight Rises let me just
say this trilogy is just amazing is it
make it's hard prep it's between Lord of
the Rings trilogy and Batman trilogy for
best trilogy ever it's it's spectacular
so we're reaching The Dark Knight Rises
it is great it is so conservative the
entire film is basically about why
Bernie Sanders is a tool bag I'll split
her a little bit the preview okay so of
course the villain in this one is Bane's
played by Tom Hardy and Bane is
basically a an anarchist socialist right
he's an anarchist in the sense that he
wants to tear down the entire society
he's a socialist in the sense that he
wants to control the entire society from
the top down and his whole thing is that
there's this gap between the rich and
the poor in Gotham and everything is
terrible in Gotham and will let the city
tear itself apart but he's actually the
one who's in control the whole time it's
not the city tearing itself apart is him
tearing the city apart and there's this
whole premise which is that Thane is
extremely tough because he had a rough
childhood and because he grew up in in
this pit and so because he was born in
the darkness that he's tougher than
Bruce Wayne who simply kind of chose the
darkness and acclimated to it because
Bruce Wayne grew up rich and then the
movie is about how that doesn't matter
what matters is the qualities you
cultivate in yourself not the stuff that
is inborn in you it's just it's such a
it's such an inherently conservative
film dark night by the way he's also a
deeply conservative film my friend
Andrew Clavin
I remember wrote an op-ed about the Dark
Knight and when she pointed out that the
entire thing is a metaphor for why the
surveillance state is sometimes
necessary but then should be destroyed
once it's unnecessary which is
absolutely true so if you if you're
looking to for a great rewatchable the
entire Batman trilogy just fantastic
Dark Knight Rises is spectacular it is
underrated because of how good the Dark
Knight is but it is maybe the best movie
of the of the tens so Christopher Nolan
is our greatest filmmaker no question
about it
so if you want to do something enjoyable
tonight watch watch Dark Knight Rises
okay time for some things that I hate
all righty so as I said before being a
woman means you have a superpower the
superpower is you get to grow a another
human being in you and then give birth
to the human being by the way your body
changes as you're giving birth to the
human being like hormones are released
that make your joints looser that change
your physical structure almost to make
it easier to birth at the baby your your
pain receptors are blocked in certain
ways so that you don't feel the pain as
much you literally get a superpower like
the last two months your pregnancy you
get a superpower beyond the superpower
of being able to actually expand your
body to grow human being inside of it
and then you have a superpower after
which is you can feed a human being with
your body which is just unbelievable
that's incredible
so I watched that for the third time
with with my newest child who's gorgeous
again thank God and I thought to myself
now that seems like if you're a woman
you want to brag about like unique
things that women can do that would be
it right of all the unique things that
women can do and this is not to say
women can't do many of the same things
that men can do women are brilliant my
wife is a doctor as I've mentioned 1
million times on this program and I'm
very proud of her for that but being a
doctor is something a man can do and
it's something a woman can do you know
something only a woman can do and not a
man who pretends to be a woman or
believes he's a woman only a woman can
do it giving birth to and nurturing a
child in the way a woman can okay that's
a superhero power it's unbelievable and
it's cool the fact that feminist
movement has degraded this is incredible
and the fact that the feminist movement
has turned a key indicator of femininity
into a Mark of Cain that if you are a
woman who gets pregnant and gives birth
to children in a married family you are
now bad right you've done something
wrong you've betrayed your feminine
power that true power is this doing the
same stuff that men can do true non
power is doing stuff that only women can
do and this is why abortion has become a
sacrament because abortion is a
testament to the idea that true
femininity is not in your natural
capacity to be to do things that only
females can do true femininity lies
instead in your capacity to deny your
femininity and then go do the same kind
of things that men do and again women
can do all those things well also having
the super power these are not mutually
exclusive you can be a doctor and a
mother you can be a comedian and a
mother you can do all of these things
but instead abortion has become a
sacrament and it is something that's
celebrated so we mentioned that Chuck
Schumer rally a little bit earlier that
was the headline that was not really the
headline the headline
should have been what people were saying
at this rally because the left has
decided that abortion is not just
something that is a necessary evil
which is a bad argument but at least
takes into account the moral gravitas of
the act they've decided that abortion is
a positive good it is something that
ought to be cheered and celebrated
leading Matt Kate charge was busy
Phillips an alleged comedian I say
allege because I've never seen her do
anything funny so busy Phillips gave a
speech at this rally that is the speech
of a Bond villain I'm not kidding this
is a speech I'll explain in a second
this is a speech ooh a Bond villain
here's Busy Philipps explaining why
she's so happy she had an abortion at 15
sitting in Los Angeles in my beautiful
office of my own late-night talk show
soon I would be driving my hybrid car to
my beautiful high because because
because I was allowed bodily autonomy at
15 that is evil okay that's full-on evil
way like normally when you hear people
talk about the abortions they've had
it's because I wasn't ready to handle a
child bad bad reason but at least not
this sometimes you hear people say well
the child wouldn't been warned it would
have had a bad life horrible reason not
this I'm rich because I killed the baby
is what I mean it's Michelle Williams
said at the Oscars to remember she said
that that she was happy that she'd had
an abortion because it allowed her to
have this acting career busy Phil I mean
that is a Bond villain speech right
before bond escapes and then takes down
the bill and that's the bond own speech
do you see all of this rich this is a
rich veterans you Mr Bond view all of
the beautiful things around you you see
this gorgeous mansion do you see my
staff of Vader's servants do you see the
vast grounds of my estate and his vast
empire I have built yeah do you see all
that that never would have been possible
if I had not murdered all of the natives
progress is reliant on the death of
innocents Mr Bond as you know as you
well know Mr Bond and then you're like
okay Obon kills that guy I mean like wow
that's that that's real bad
nobody should do anything bad Busy
Philipps obviously what she's saying
they're horrendous evil right if if this
were a corporate head saying this you
don't understand this right if a
corporate head said let's say let's go
on Michael Bloomberg right let's go
Michael Bloomberg if Michael Bloomberg
said you know what my company wouldn't
have been as profitable if I hadn't told
women to go get abortions you'd be like
oh that's terrible that's a terrible
thing to say
profiting off the deaths of innocence
like that's that's an awful thing to say
Busy Philipps
believing that it's an excuse for her to
kill a baby so that she can have a nice
office so I guess that it's
proportionate now so she had killed like
four babies then she'd be a billionaire
I doubt lady be like Oprah if she'd
killed four babies so that was one line
from the from the rally other lines from
the rally because this one is
particularly great also so from the
rally one of these women gets up and she
starts saying let's hear it for women
who have had abortions whoa big round of
applause for killing babies and then she
realizes wait a second not only women
have abortions some men have abortions
too how you ask well because everybody
has lost their mind so she explains that
we need to cheer for trans people who
have had abortions
[Applause]
what dear friend transpose to have a
Porsche
okay um yeah yeah okay final clip we
shoot it to leave the execrable
congresswoman from Ashiya
just terrible so um she was also trying
to explain that with that people are
pro-life cuz they want to control one's
bodies which has always been the
stupidest argument for me in the world
again sexist men typically want to
control women's bodies not so they can
make babies with them but so they can
have sex with them right this is what
Bill Clinton said about Monica Lewinsky
effectively okay but Rasheeda Talib
she's like well if you were gonna be
pro-life if you're gonna be pro-life
then maybe you shouldn't you should just
not want to have sex with ladies okay
but she did not only say that she said
she said something she actually said
I'll give it to her she said something
on which there is wide bipartisan
agreement here is his Rasheeda Talib
expressing maybe the most bipartisan
sentiment that I've heard in the recent
past the Michigan Legislature for six
years used to say people to people yo yo
you know what you're so freakin obsessed
with what I decide to do with my body
maybe you shouldn't even want to have
sex with me okay unruhe she had sleeve
done done wide bipartisan agreement 100%
approval no one wants to have sex with
Rasheeda Talib everybody's on board well
done that is not a case in favor of
abortion but at least admit that when
there's agreement there's agreement I'm
glad we could come to consensus on one
thing which is nobody wants to have sex
with Rasheeda delete that's that's
exciting stuff all right well we will be
back here on Monday or later today for
two additional hours of content go check
out daily we're calm subscribe right now
if you used the promo code never
socialist you get 25% off of a
subscription which is a great deal
otherwise have yourself a wonderful you
know what knock off early today take the
next couple of days off we'll be back
here on Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis clever and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you